Now that users can log in to my system,
I should make a way to protect
the resources they can access.
For this example, let's assume there's
a resource exposed by this API that
needs to be available
only to registered users.
This resource is accessed at
the end point /protected_resource.
To protect this resource,
I'm going to use an extension
in Flask called Flask-HTTPAuth.
Flask httpauth is a simple
extension that provides basic and
digest http authentication for
Flask routes.
With Flask httpauth,
an end point is protected by adding
the auth.login_requried decerator to it.
Flask.httpauth needs to be
given some more information,
to know how to validate
user credentials,
which is implemented through
the verify password call back.
It is given a username and password and
returns true if the combination
is valid and false if not.
Flask HTTP off invokes
this callback function
whenever it needs to validate
a username and password pair.
This function simply finds
the user by their username,
verifies the password using
the verify password method.
And if the credentials are valid,
then the user has stored it in
FLASK's G object, so
that the view function can use it.
Let's send a request to my server now,
and
first see what happens if I use
an incorrect username or password.
I can't access the resource.
But using the correct username and
password, my request gets
the protected resource for the user.
Check out the instructor notes to see
the code implemented in this video.